when you use dating apps you do take a
risk cause you never know who you're
gonna run into walking up to the door
before the date with Harley there's a
few butterflies and you're always a
little bit trepidatious because
obviously you're only going by the
pictures that they've posted up but
unless you take the chance you're never
gonna know she answered and I said Oh
Harley she said druing I said yeah and
she said oh you know it was kind of a
bit of a wink-wink moment where she was
like oh yeah okay so I felt pretty good
you know to start off with
she was this punk rock chick she was a
little bit sort of bum lift the center
looked very interesting off to a good
start I walked into the lounge room and
I was stuck at I could feel a presence
behind me and she said oh no no no no
Andrew um smokey likes to be pet from
this side of the table and literally
moved me I didn't know she was joking
around but I was like oh okay whatever
so I sat down and turned over my
shoulder and she's been like a ballet
kind of move and she's doing all these
sort of stretching and things like that
and she said I used to be a ballet
dancer I'm just doing some stretches I
was like okay look I'm a gardener
sometimes you know I'm bent down for so
many hours of the day so I can
understand that and at the time the
Winter Olympics were on so watching the
figure skating or sudden how he screams
out that's not a your [__] do a
triple salchow toe loop you [__]
oh [__] off you know just calm down you
know I thought she did all right
oh no and she start started to complain
you know that's a rookie mistake and
she's meant to be a lot better than that
um so I was like okay how's that go come
and sit down you know next to me so we
can get to know each other a bit more no
son I heard this Fang hmm so I looked
over and found that she was lying on the
floor and sort of groaning and moaning
and so ah you know are you okay
oh I think I slipped over so I thought
we'll get on to a topic that we'd spoken
to previously so I said I'll Harley got
me to have a look at your bougainvillea
oh yeah yeah that's right you're a
gardener you know I want to show you my
Japanese garden so we went outside it
was quite dark at his home and then like
all sudden something started hitting me
and Holly starts laughing I'm kicking
you with my panties you know in my hand
I'm gonna do that do that you're gonna
hit me on the other and she's obviously
a great time that she's laughing every
time she did something weird I was
thinking to myself it's important just
to show people respect you know give
them a bit of time and I get to know
them we sat down Holly and I had this
really yeah quite close conversation so
yeah really getting to know is which was
good considering what had happened up
until this point she said she was doing
it was either psychology or psychiatry
course and she was halfway through went
to grab the vodka Nicky and I hang
Holly's fallen on the ground again
hmm I'm like you know not again kneeling
over her and I realized that she's
completely out she's sweating profusely
start to freak out here like I go well
you know what the [__] do I do here so
I'm so lightly tapping her cheeks and
sort of trying to cool her down and just
talk to her hey are you okay
after a while I didn't get anything I
kind of got a call the ambulance
I sort of explained this story that I
was on this first tinder day just as I
was about to get to the point where they
asked me for the address
partly knocked the phone out of my hand
she's like I just said I look like she's
coming through and I was like Oh Holly
you know are you okay I don't know what
you've had tonight but you're not in a
good state is there someone we can call
you some muttered someone's name i Julie
Julie okay uh I'll call Julie for you I
said what's your PIN number on your
phone and then this real Wicked Witch
kind of voice she said I said well how
am I gonna call your friend because I'm
I'm leaving and she said ah oh can you
just put me on my bed
I kind of felt like some sort of guinea
pig for maybe some sort of research to
do with her psychology psychiatry course
I could tell that you know she'd have
the smarts to do that so I picked Holley
up next thing I know she screamed Oh
Julie Julie Julie and I said yes yes
I've been trying to call her but you
won't give me a PIN number and she
points at the wall and on the wall was a
quite a large fake check and it says
Julie by this summer I've had enough I
thought I just need to get get out of
here
I said I'm going home I'm sorry and I
heard him mutter something under her
under a voice and I turned around and
said what but what did you call me and
she said I'll call you a douche bag I
just looked at and I said right I said
you're nuttier than squirrel poo and I'm
getting the [__] out of here and walked
off and got in my car and went home
[Music]
I can pretty much get laid through
Facebook and snapchat and I don't really
need to utilize dating apps the reason
for that I guess is my ability to close
I work full-time mandated Friday but I
also have my online persona which you
know attracts women it's the sex drugs
and rock and roll side to what I do and
whether it be picking up girls drinking
alcohol or you know having 15 shots of
tequila in a row and throwing up on the
bar it it is really that that that
harnesses that crazy side of my persona
probably having you up to three and a
half thousand people view of snapchat so
people watch my snapchats religiously
Fame Jim gain Fame and fun for me it's
pretty cool people do recognize me you
know people might wave from the other
side of the bar or come up with your
photo I have my saying that here we are
I mean all of it getting greedy
[__] in my three catchphrases and they
sort of sort of took off sort of start
my snapchats with them personal brand is
really important to me photos are a big
thing you know top off at the beach
obviously putting a good filter on that
well after the gym the sweaty you know
I'm a real masculine sort of man look is
something that really gets a girl's got
a lot of my snapchats will be as sort of
a journey of my knife so we'll start
with you know the pre dreams and then
you know snapchat on stage with the DJ
and I might need a girl via snapchat
with her and they'll say would you like
to kiss me on my snapchat we'll go home
I will always snapchat the next day as a
bit of a laugh filming you as she's
doing the walk of shame I choose my
targets wisely I think you can
definitely tell through people's profile
pictures whether they're gonna be an
easy target or or somebody that's gonna
be difficult to get home and get into
bed last Saturday night I caught up with
this girl through my online presence
she's been constantly text messaging me
and the text messages have been up and
down between photos and dirty talk and
she's almost what we call a froth a
frother is somebody that froth us at the
mouth for what you do so they they love
you they will follow you around they'll
write on your facebook fanpage wall
she blonde got stuck cry - she's got
good kids on an on my scale I'm from a 1
to 10 I probably read her a probably a
solid six and a half to seven a couple
of beers she was definitely a nine yeah
I'll probably write my looks at a solid
eight now one thing led to another and
there was a few kisses exchanged and I
really got made a mine came down and he
shot me a few few dirty looks I think my
mate definitely liked the girl at the
bar he has a jealous streak later that
night he sort of confronted one another
again and it did end with a few few
choice words and that sort of led him to
a bit of a push and shove and a little
bit before I guess not - not to my own
horn but I definitely came out the
better at the end of the day the girl
came home with me
it was face down ass up having really
having a good old time
not to be honest I can't remember much
more than that because I clean passed
out she was very quick out of the the
house shortly afterwards a lot of girls
tend to as I would say find me [__] me
forget me the next day I put a phone
call in to my maid I never put hoes
before Bros and perhaps I've stepped
over the line this time we were mates
again and we're having a bit of a chat
and he then sort of let me know few
select things which have sort of advice
suppose led me to head to the doctor to
to get myself nice and checked up with
five weeks into the year I've had seven
girls I think this year already
you know things do flare up on the on
occasion the chlamydia
it could be herpes in the worst worst
case because that's certainly something
I can't get get rid of and that'll
that'll definitely be the end of the end
of my sexual career for sure that'll be
made done having
[Music]
you